Point is that I,
one of the things that I told you,
if you are going to be my client,
as you just don't,
you don't just tell your
audience your assaults,
you owe your audience your life.
Uh,
Jordan had helped me 20
years to articulate what I
meant by that and it's simply
that if deserve to be a superstar,
then you,
you will become an iconic figure.
And 12 year old kids will paste posters
this view up on their bedroom walls and
you will be,
you know,
the concept of the Trellis.
You wrote a tomato plant on a trellis.
Well you will be the trellis on which
people row you will be the role model.
So your life is one of the most
important things you have to offer.
But I wasn't just after
their superficial life.
I was after I was after this.
When you sit down,
okay,
of an afternoon,
let's say at two o'clock in the afternoon
with a blank computer screen or a
blank piece of paper and
you need to write a lyric.
You feel as if you could,
you don't know how you've ever
written a lyric in your life.
You certainly know you can't
write another one again.
And by four o'clock in the afternoon,
on a good day,
there's a lyric in front of you
like four o'clock in the afternoon.
A really,
really rare good day.
That lyric is so perfect in itself,
but it feels like it
wrote itself through you.
Yeah.
When you go on stage,
if you see the dog,
the pupils of the audience dilating,
if you see their faces melting,
losing individual characteristics.
If you see their energy fusing into
a collective energy rather than just
individual energies.
And if that collective force reaches,
uh,
a,
a pseudopod out to you and hooks into
something inside of you that's bigger than
yourself and again,
you'll feel like an empty
pipe and something inside
you was transmogrifying all
of this energy and flooding
it back down to the audience.
In a riverbed Vitori circuit and
you have an out of body experience.
You Watch yourself from the ceiling as
you are dance that self inside of you,
the dances you onstage,
that is your fucking goddamn soul.
And that's mark by and 10 to find.
And that's what I intend
to introduce you to.
Why?
Because you are about to become an icon.
And if you become an icon,
you have to be a force that takes hundreds
of thousands or even tens of millions
of kids who feel lost in the world,
who don't dare express their feelings
because there are no except socially
acceptable words for their
feelings and who feel crazy,
isolated and alone.
And you,
by revealing what's deep inside of you,
will validate what's deep inside of them.